XCOM 2 is already filled with a bunch of
crazy custom made content if you like
the Star Wars helmets or puppy gun mods
you'll love the first official expansion
it's called anarchy's children and aside
from sounding like an awesome 80s punk
band it's bringing a ton of new
customization options when it hits pc on
March seventeenth an turkeys children is
filled with new hairstyles face masks
armor and a bunch more custom options
for your soldiers and there's definitely
some Mad Max influence in there you can
grab just the add-on for five bucks but
it's also included with XCOM tues $20
reinforcement pack two more add-ons
alien hunters and shen's last gift are
slated for release this summer XCOM to
hit pc back in February ps4 and xbox one
versions of the game have been talked
about but developer fire axis has
nothing to announce at this time if they
do you'll hear about it from GameSpot
I'm Tony you can follow me on twitter at
chain-gun Pope and I suddenly have an
urge to go watch fury road